[Music]  the world is full  of light  [Music]  this is my first time in new york city  i want to be happy here i want to make a  life a home  [Music]  are you ready  tonight is about family  the first gringo boy who smiles at you  i never seen you before  you're not puerto rican  is that okay  do you want to start world war iii  [Music]  you know i wake up to everything i know  either getting sold or wrecked or being  taken over by people that i don't like  you keep away from him as long as you're  in my house  i'm a grown up now bernardo i'm gonna  think for myself  tony  we need you if we're going to work  are you  wonderful  [Applause]  if you go with him  no one will ever forgive you  [Music]  life matters even more than love  [Music]  [Music]  you